so this is technically a birthday
podcast uh what do you love most about
getting older
um it's like a it the confirmation
that comes from
getting more and more data which
basically says yeah the first time you
thought that thing it was actually right
because the second third and fourth and
fifth time
um it turned out the exact same way in
other words
um there have been a few times in my
life where
I did not feel
easy about something I did I felt
a signal for my body this is not good
um and I didn't trust it early on but I
knew it was there
and then
two or three
bad experiences later
I'm able to say ah every single time
there was a signal from the body
informing my mind
this is not good
now the reverse has also been true that
there have been a number of instances in
which I feel sort of immediate delight
and there's this kind of almost
astonishingly
simple experience of feeling
um comfortable with somebody or at peace
with something or delighted at an
experience and it turns out all
literally all of those experiences and
people turned out to be experiences in
people that are still in my life and
that I
um still Delight in every day in other
words what's great about getting older
is that you stop questioning
the signals that come from the I think
deeper recesses of your nervous system
to say hey this is not good or hey this
is great more of this whereas I think in
my teens
my 20s my 30s I'm 40 almost 48 I'll be
48 next month
um
I I didn't trust I didn't listen I
actually put a lot of work into
overriding those signals and learning to
fight through them thinking that somehow
that was making me tougher or somehow
that was making me
um
smarter when in fact in the end those
people that you meet that are you know
difficult or you know there are other
names for it you know it's like like in
the end you're like another person's
piece of you know or
um this person is amazing and they're
really wonderful and I felt that from go
so you've learned to trust your gut
versus like the the influences of other
people's opinions um I've learned to
trust my gut versus the uh the forebrain
over analysis overriding the gut other
people often in my life have had great
Optics
right I've I've benefited tremendously
from an early age of being in a large
community of what's been mostly guys by
some close female friends and always
have as well who will tell me that
that's a bad decision or this person not
so good or be careful or they're great
or that's great so oftentimes my
community and the people around me have
been more aligned with the correct
Choice than not really yes really when
you were younger like like transparents
and so on
I don't recall ever really listening to
my parents that much you know I grew up
in a you know we don't have to go back
to my childhood thing but my sense thank
you I learned that recently in a
psilocybin Journey
um my first my first high-dose
psilocybin Journey which was um welcome
back done with a clinician thank you
very much thank you I was worried there
for a second at one point am I not
coming back but in in any event
um yeah I grew up with some wild kids
you know I would say about a third of my
friends from childhood or dead or in
jail
um about a third have gone on to do
tremendously impressive things start
companies excellent athletes academics
um scientists and um and clinicians and
and then about a third are living their
lives is become more typical I just mean
um that they are happy family people uh
with jobs that they mainly
um serve the function to make money
they're not sort of career into their
career for career's sake but
um
so some of my friends early on gave me
some bad ideas
um but most of the time my bad ideas
came from
um
overriding the signals that I knew that
my body and I would say my body and
brain were telling me uh to obey and no
I say body and brain is that there's
this brain region the insula which um
that does many things but it represents
our sense of internal uh sensation in
terreception and I was talking to Paul
Conti about this you know as who as you
know
um I trim respect tremendously I think
he's one of the smartest people I've
ever met
um I think for different reasons he and
Mark Andreessen are some of the like
smartest people I've ever met but Paul's
level of insight into the human psyche
is is absolutely astounding and um and
um he
says the opposite of what most
people say about the brain which is most
people say oh the supercomputer of the
brain is the forebrain it's like a
monkey brain with a extra real estate
put on there and the forebrain is what
makes us human
um and gives us our our superpowers Paul
has said
um and he's done a whole series on
Mental Health that's coming out from our
uh podcast in September so this is not
an attempt to plug that but he'll
elaborate wait you're doing a thing with
fall we already did yeah so Paul oh nice
yeah so Paul Conte shot up uh we did it
he and I sat down he did a four episode
series on Mental Health this is not
mental illness mental health about how
to explore one's own subconscious
explore the self build and cultivate
um the generative Drive you'll learn
more about what that is from him he's
far more eloquent um and and clearer
than I am
um and he provides essentially a a set
of steps to explore the self that does
not require that you work with a
therapist this is self-exploration that
that is rooted in
Psychiatry it's rooted in neuroscience
and I don't think this information
exists anywhere else I'm not aware that
it exists anywhere else and um he
essentially distills it all down to one
uh eight and a half by eleven sheet
which we provide for people and
um
he says there I don't want to give too
much away because I would detract from
what he does so beautifully but if I
tried and I wouldn't accomplish it
anyway
um but he said and I believe that the
subconscious is the super computer of
the brain all the stuff working
underneath our conscious awareness
that's driving our feelings and our what
we think are the decisions that we've
thought through so carefully and that
only by exploring the subconscious and
understanding it a little bit
um can we actually uh
improve ourselves over time and I agree
I think that so that the mistake is to
think that thinking can override at all
it's a certain style of introspection
and thinking that um allows us to read
the signals from our body read the
signals from our brain integrate the the
knowledge that we're collecting about
ourselves and and to use all that in
ways that are really adaptive and
generative for us